bonsoir Monsieur Trudel
bonsoir allons-y donc en terme simple
avec ce que c'est ce projet de loi
séance cette nouvelle loi qui entre
désormais en vigueur son objectif est-ce
que ça va changer
en fait c'est une loi qui chante qui
vient intégrer dans le champ de la loi
sur la radio Diffusion cette loi qui
régit les activités des radios et des
télévisions au Canada ça vient intégrer
les entreprises qui agissent sur
Internet ces fameuses plateformes en
ligne Netflix Amazon Prime et ainsi de
suite et donc ces plateformes qui
jusqu'à maintenant étaient exclus des
obligations qui existent pour tous les
autres radio diffusionnent c'est à dire
de contribuer à la production canadienne
autrement dit le principe qui existe
depuis très longtemps au Canada c'est de
faire en sorte que les entreprises qui
tirent des revenus du marché canadien
des médias
réinvestissent une partie de ses revenus
là dans la production canadienne et donc
là c'est obligation là va être étendue
aussi aux plateformes étrangères comme
Netflix et les autres qui
sont captés et sont fréquentés par le
public canadien donc je comprends bien
que ça sert à obliger à contraindre si
on veut ces entreprises à soutenir à
produire à fomenter du contenu canadien
mais par quel moyen de quelle façon
alors le projet de loi la loi sur la
diffusion en ligne va permettre au CRTC
qui est en fait l'organisme qui va être
en quelque sorte le maître d'oeuvre de
l'application de cette loi-là le certifu
va avoir l'autorité pour prendre des
ordonnances des règlements qui vont en
quelque sorte imposer des obligations
aux entreprises obligations de
réinvestir dans la production canadienne
mais aussi des obligations de s'assurer
que les algorithmes qui sont utilisés
pour aiguiller les contenus vers les
spectateurs mettre en valeur et valorise
les contenus les émissions canadiennes
les émissions canadiennes émanant des
des groupes minoritaires au Canada des
populations des peuples autochtones et
des évidemment du français des
francophones et aussi des anglophones
donc obligation de faire en sorte que
les oeuvres canadiennes soient visibles
par ceux qui syntonisent ces plateformes
en ligne donc évidemment les exactement
les mêmes normes qui sont exigés depuis
des années aux médias traditionnel ici
au Canada sauf que là on les a pris
qu'il y a des entreprises pour la
plupart étrangères les conservateurs au
cours des derniers mois ça peut être
retardé pas mal le processus ont soulevé
toutes sortes d'inquiétudes notamment ce
qui est après la liberté d'expression
quel est le lien avec ce que vous venez
de nous dire est-ce qu'il y a lieu de
s'inquiéter à cet égard
en fait ce sont des inquiétudes qui
apparaissent un petit peu surréaliste
pour quiconque prend la peine de lire la
loi sur la radio Diffusion et le projet
de l'océan aussi puisque ce projet de
loi là modifie une loi et réitère le
principe selon lequel le CRTC doit
lorsqu'il applique la loi lorsqu'il met
des en place des règlements doit
s'assurer de respecter la liberté
d'expression et l'indépendance de des
entreprises en matière de programmation
donc l'argument sur la possible menace à
la liberté d'expression moi ça fait une
quarantaine d'années que je suis ce
domaine-là au quotidien et j'avoue que
ça me semble être je sais pas sur quoi
ça repose hormis la fabulation très bien
maintenant monsieur Trudel il y a une
chose qui demeure certaine c'est que
encore des questions suspens la quant à
l'application de cette loi quand on aux
outils qui seront donnés au CRTC c'est
un peu là c'est de cette façon qu'on va
mesurer
l'efficacité de cette loi qui a été donc
mise de l'avant par Pablo Rodriguez
absolument en fait ce que ça prend pour
que cette loi soit véritablement
efficace c'est un CRTC beaucoup plus
équipé mieux équipés pour comprendre
suivre de façon beaucoup plus de façon
beaucoup plus attentive les évolutions
de l'industrie et être davantage
proactif anticiper les changements
travailler avec l'industrie pour
comprendre les tendances et s'assurer
que les interventions réglementaires
qu'il met en place vont avoir
effectivement des des résultats leur
tangibles en termes de d'amélioration de
la qualité et de la quantité des
productions canadiennes et entre autres
pas seulement votre joie canadienne
[Musique]
en anglais également en français et
aussi dans les langues minoritaires les
autres minoritaires comme les langues
des peuples autochtones et donc il y a
une importante défi pour le CRTC qui est
chargé en quelque sorte de donner corps
à cette loi qui pour l'instant et
essentiellement une série principe oui
certes on se rappelle il y a un peu plus
de 20 ans avait dit non quand était venu
le moment de peut-être moderniser la loi
avec l'arrivée d'Internet ben un quart
de siècle plus tard voilà qu'on y arrive
tranquillement mais sûrement Pierre
Trudel merci beaucoup pour ces
éclaircissements
bonne journée à vous au revoir